Музыка Oh, Podcast UFO! Podcast UFO! Podcast UFO!, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcasts UFO. Heute mit Stabatize. Und Florentin will, und das war das Intro von Dan Solo, vielen Dank an Dan Solo. Ja, Florentin hat während das Intro lief gesagt, muss man ein bisschen reinkommen, worauf meine Reaktion war, er ist schlecht für ein 30 Sekunden Intro, wenn man ein bisschen reinkommen muss. Es dich, der Entschuldigung. Es gibt manche Intros, wo man einfach merkt, okay, jetzt habe ich ein bisschen Zeit. Aber beim House of Cards Intro musste man auch reinkommen. Das hat man erst in Schätzen gewusst, nachdem man nach Staffel drei gesummt hat. Subjektive Einschätzung, Serienintros im Laufe der Zeit, werden sie länger oder kürzer? Kürzer, definitiv kürzer, auf jeden Fall kürzer. Game of Thrones ist super lang. Game of Thrones ist mega lang, sehr alte Serie. House of Cards, sehr alte Serie, sehr lang. Breaking Bad, sehr kurzes Intro. Wie er spricht massiv den Punkt, den ich gerade machen will. Ich denke an so, dass die Sopranos, wo auch mal ein echt sehr langes Intro war. To Detective, auch eine alte Serie, auch ein sehr langes Intro. Das ganze Lied durch, dreieinhalb Minuten. Ich finde, es gibt manche so Intros, da kann man sich einfach reinlegen, so da weisst du einfach so, jetzt bin ich einfach abgeholt, so das dauert jetzt eine Weile, aber ist auch gut, so wenn du so an der roten Ampel hältst, du weisst, jetzt habe ich einen Moment Zeit, aber es geht dann auch los. Jetzt schön das Serienintro von To Detective an der Ampel. Dann fühlt man sich gut, ey, bist du noch nie mit dem Sopranos-Intro durch die Stadt gefahren? Nee, noch nie. Woke up this morning, got myself a gun. Das ist der Stefan Tizze. Life is a rollercoaster. Na na na na na. Stefan, wir haben uns lange nicht gesehen. Das stimmt. Ich muss davor sagen, ich bin massiv unausgeschlafen. Ich bin mega bearbeitet. Es tut mir sehr leid, es lag ein bisschen auch an mir, dass wir die letzten beiden Folgen nicht aufnehmen konnten. Ich habe beruflich sehr viel um die Ohren. Ich habe zuletzt einmal rausschneiden müssen, weil ich geheime Details verraten habe. Ich kann es dir jetzt mal irgendwann mal sagen. Ich mache gerade, ich entwickle gerade eine Serie. Das macht sehr viel Spaß, ist aber auch sehr viel Zeit, geht da drauf. Und Florentin macht nichts, aber die Sachen, die er macht, die er noch machen muss, wie Wäsche machen, wie Blumengießen, die fallen dann wiederum genau in die Zeit, wo ich mal gerade fünf Minuten habe, draußen eine schnell rauchen, dann wieder reingehen und weiter tippen. Und das überlappt sich so sehr, dass wir nicht dazu kamen, eine Serie aufzunehmen. Habe ich es ungefähr getroffen. Ziemlich perfekt genauso. Ja, und deswegen konnten wir nicht aufnehmen in den letzten zwei Wochen. Tut uns sehr grosses Sorry. Aber dafür haben wir heute eine picke packe vollgepackte Folge, denn es ist einiges geschehen in der Zeit, in der wir nicht aufnehmen konnten. Wir. Wir müssen aufräumen, wir müssen unglaublich aufräumen. Also hol die Schneeschaufel raus, Stefan Tietze, pack sie an und jetzt wird erstmal geschaufelt, jetzt wird erstmal abgearbeitet. Also ganz kurz, bevor wir wirklich mit der Folge anfangen, kurz ein paar organisatorische Dinge. Gut. Wir haben die Rubrik schon mal das letzte Mal gemacht, wir müssen sie wieder machen, Rubrik Gegendarstellung. Auch genannt, Entschuldigung. Entschuldigung. Das ist nämlich eine neue Rubrik, die mittlerweile mehr kommt und wahrscheinlich auch wieder häufiger hervorgekramt werden muss, weil wir grossen Schwachsinn reden. Eine der unbelebtesten Rubriken tatsächlich. Vor allem in der Enten- Community, wo wir gesagt haben, man soll sie mit Nudeln füttern. Das ist massiv schief gelaufen. Man soll sie auf gar keinen Fall mit Nudeln füttern. Jetzt haben wir dann gesagt, also das ist quasi die Gegendarstellung der Gegendarstellung, wir haben dann gesagt, macht es einfach mit Brot. Jetzt, wiederum, haben sehr viele Tierschützer geschrieben, auch auf gar keinen Fall mit Brot füttern, niemals mit Brot füttern, alles scheiße, lasst es einfach. Deswegen sagen wir heute, kein Brot, nur M&Ms, Enten lieben M&Ms, ausschliesslich M&Ms. Kein Brot, keine Nudeln. Auf gar keinen Fall, dafür schön Peanut und die regulären beide, aber es muss auf jeden Fall M&M sein. Ja, holy fuck, da haben uns bei der Enten-Community sind wir durch. Aber ich würde sagen, da sind wir dem eigentlichen Shitstorm nochmal ausgewichen. Also das ist gerade nochmal gut gegangen. Wir haben nur so einen Hauch mitbekommen. Aber wir sind noch nicht durch. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dir aufgefallen ist mit der Gegendarstellungsliste. Weil, Punkt zwei, ich habe gesagt, bei Netflix hat jeder quasi bekommt personalisiert, angezeigt, je nachdem, was er für einen Geschmack hat, das Artdesign, um dann drauf zu klicken auf die jeweilige Serie. Stell sich raus, alle haben diese Köpfe. Es gibt nicht einen, der was anderes hat. Das habe ich sehr, sehr gerne beobachtet, weil du gesagt hast, so, oh, ich bin der Köpfe-Typ. Und dann habe ich ganz viele Posts gesehen bei uns, at Podcast UFO, oh, ich bin genau wie Stefan auch ein Podcast-Typ. Ja, von letzter Zeit hat sich gefreut und jeder hat geschrieben, es kam keine, es kam wirklich keine Nachricht von jemandem, wo das anders war. Stefan und ich sind seelenverwandt, ich liebe auch Köpfe, ich liebe sie einfach. Stellt sich raus, nope, alles selbe. Alles Köpfe. Kennst du diese kleinen Schokoriegel mit Milchfüllung? Bei mir ist da ein Riesenkopf vorne auf der Packung. Das ist total krass, mir geht's ja genau wie dir. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber bei mir ist es ein Riesenkopf. Leute, was ist da los? Ich bin der Köpfe-Typ einfach. Es ist so, so Werbung für so Sprachschulen. Bei mir sind da immer riesige Köpfe drauf. Krass, wie das, die moderne Technik heute. Also das ist so krass, der erkennt genau, wer der Köpfe-Typ ist und wer nicht. Wer ist zum Beispiel der Baum-Typ? Bei anderen gibt es vielleicht Bäume drauf, bei mir sind es Köpfe, aber es ist krass einfach. Ja, mach dieses Schulbücher-Designs eigentlich, weil da gibt es nämlich das eine Schulbuch, wo eine glückliche Klasse, es sind ja immer glückliche Schüler auf Schulbüchern, also spanisch, jeder hat dieses spanische Buch, wie hieß es bei euch, ich weiss nicht, wie es bei uns hieß. Wir hatten gar kein spanisch in der Schule. Wir hatten das typische spanische Buch, wo mal diese CD lief, Eraciciano, Eraciciano, was viel zu schnell gesprochen hat, diese ganzen Sprachsachen, da konnte ich mal nicht, ich habe Texte lang Spanisch geschrieben, aber sobald man spanische Leute gesprochen hat, ist man viel zu schnell, Erasicio Uno, hat man nicht verstanden. Und dieses Buch, da waren glückliche Schüler drauf, wie eigentlich auf jedem vernünftigen Schulbuch. Und es gibt das eine Buch, wo Leute, wo glückliche Schüler drauf sind, die ein Schulbuch in der Hand haben, nämlich das mit dem Motiv des Schulbuchs, was man gerade sieht. Das ist brillant, das ist ein absolute Inception. Aber wie haben die dieses Foto gemacht, haben die es mit grünen Büchern gemacht und dann danach, nachdem das Foto entstanden ist, die grünen Punkte durch das Foto ersetzt, was sie gerade gemacht haben? Ja, oder die haben das eigentlich für ein anderes Buch gemacht und haben einfach gesagt, ja, pass auf, jede Sprache, jedes Thema, Mathe, Physik, alles packen wir drauf und dann müssen wir natürlich das ändern. Das war so clever. Wir hatten, ich hatte Französisch, ich glaube, wir hatten Französisch eins, zwei, drei und vier, auf eins fröhliche Schüler, zwei fröhliche Schüler, drittes Louvre, viertens fröhliche Schüler. Ja, sechstens spanischsprachige Schüler. Fassism drei passiert, wo hatten die keine Zeit, dieass uns mal ein bisschen was anderes machen, wie so ein Konzeptalbum. Jetzt mal ganz crazy. Ich dachte, wo du angefangen hast mit Band eins, fröhliche Schüler, dass sie immer unglücklicher werden. Dass sie mit jedem Jahr Französisch ein bisschen mehr, am Ende ist es einfach nur so ein Galgen, hängt am Ende einfach noch, so ein Strick. Einer wurde durch so eine Getränkemaschine ersetzt. Was ist mit Pierre?
Où est Pierre?
Aucune Idee, c'est la Pierre et son automat de ver.
Ja, aber hier auch noch mal
ein großes Sorry an die
Lass uns einfach nichts mehr
ich meine, wir verrennen uns bei jedem Thema
ich habe nämlich noch ein Thema auf der Gegenstandsstellungsliste
weil wir haben mal vor ein paar
Wochen hast du mal gesagt, dass man im Einkaufswagen bei Amazon Dinge reinlegen sollte, damit sie billiger werden. Auch hier ein großes, großes Sorry, die werden dann teurer. Die werden teurer. Viele haben mir geschickt, so, oh, ich habe deinen Tipp befolgt, geil, vielen Dank, mal gucken, zwei Tage später, wütender Smiley, fuck, jetzt muss ich fünf Euro mehr zahlen für meinen Plasma-Fernseher. Also es tut mir richtig leid, Leute, sorry nochmal an der Stelle. Es tut mir wirklich... Wie kommen wir uns dem Entschuldigen nicht mehr raus? Wirklich leid. Aber das ist so ein bisschen, wahrscheinlich ist das ein Gerücht, das Amazon in die Welt gesetzt hat. Das ist genau wie mit diesem, dieser Casino-Trick, da haben wir auch schon drüber gesprochen. Dieser, dass man immer doppelt so viel auf Rot setzt, man sieht immer auf Rot oder Schwarz. Ja, aber das ist Mathematik. Nee, und die, da gibt's auf YouTube ... Aber das ist ein Fakt. Nein, da gibt's auf YouTube ganz viele Videos, die die erklären. Und diese Videos werden ja von Online-Casinos produziert. Damit Leute diesen Trick in Online-Casinos machen, um da zu verlieren. Ist ja klar. What?! Wer macht denn diesen ... Wer macht diese Videos? Jeder, der diesen Trick ausprobiert hat, hat sein gesamtes Geld verloren. Du willst mir sagen, Karl F94, der YouTube-Channel, den jeder abonniert hat, der ist vom MGM-Grant finanziert worden. Es tut mir leid, ich muss Karl F einfach seine haarige Maske vom Kopf reißen. Es ist im Endeffekt winwinwin.org, es ist im Grunde dasselbe. Wie gesagt, wer macht diese Videos? Die, die den Trick anwenden und verlieren, sagen nicht, da habe ich jetzt 100 Euro verloren, jetzt mal ein YouTube-Video. Das finde ich clever, seine eigene Nachfrage schaffen. Oder halt Werbung auf die falsche Art machen. Und genauso ist bei Amazon wahrscheinlich auch so. Dadurch hat Amazon richtig viel Geld verloren, gewonnen, verdient, dadurch, dass ich Unsinn erzählt habe. Ja, Unsinn erzählt. Das ist genauso wie Trump oder so, dass wenn der einmal einen Kommentar bringt wie diese Firma ist schlecht, dann sinkt der Aktienkurs sofort. Ja genau wie Elon Musk, der getwittert hat, dass Tesla kurz vor dem Bankrott ist am 1. April und meine fucking Aktien einfach so minus 5%. Ey, die Börse versteht keine Gags, das habe ich dir aber auch damals schon gesagt. Ja, aber ohne Scheiss.
Also ganz im Ernst, wenn das wirklich, also da sind ja Milliarden verloren gegangen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie die verloren gehen, weil das existiert ja auch nicht.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass da jetzt irgendwie, aber es ist schon krass.
Warum ist die Börse so empfindlich und ich würde fast sagen zu empfindlich, wenn die auf den ersten April-Gag reinfällt. Ich würde sagen, da hat er wirklich so satiremässig schon krass irgendwie was offengelegt, was da nicht funktioniert. Ich finde, Elon Musk hat da wirklich mit der Fingerspitze der Satire gearbeitet und herausgefunden, dass die Börsen nicht funktionieren. Also du willst sagen, der hat den Börsenzeitgeist auf dem Zahn gefühlt, oder was? Der hat den Börsenzeitgeist auf dem Zahn gefühlt, ja. Irgendwann wird ein Krieg durch den Gag ausgelöst, hundertprozentig.
Es gibt hundertprozentig irgendwann Krieg durch den Gag.
War doch locker schon so.
Meinst du?
Ja, klar.
Was war das mit Toja eigentlich nochmal?
Haben die nicht...
Ja, das war ein Gag zum Beispiel.
War das nicht ein Gag? War das nicht so ein Prank mit der Helena?
Ich hab die Helena...
War das nicht so ein Prank?
Komm, du versteckst dich hier auf dem Boden.
Komm, versteck dich hier.
Alter, geil.
Du versteck dich hier unter dem Deck.
Hier?
Dann fahren wir nach Toja.
Und dann denken die Kriegen so, wo ist Helena, wo ist Helena, wo ist Helena was ist weg? Was sind das denn hier für Segler? Mach jetzt, what, shit, what stuff? Das sind hunderte Schiffe! Und jetzt leider war das Wort der Trojaner für Prank, das für Krieg. In Griechischen. Griechischen. Ach, Leute. Ah, das hätten wir. Damn it. Und dann in die Ferse oder in die Achilles-Szene oder was? Man hat ja manchmal ... Wo hat Achilles gesagt, hat man ihn getroffen? Ah, nicht in meine ... Ich-Ferse. Das ist ein doofer Name, Leute. Das ist ein Scheissname, sorry, noch mal. Weil alle müssen Du-Ferse sagen. Ah, nicht in ausgerechnet ausgerechnet, ihr wisst schon, das war es mal hinten am Fuß.
Hey, da könnt ihr mich nicht treffen.
Wir haben ja mal gedreht eine Zeit lang, als ich noch einen Job habe, hatte er vor, glaube ich, sieben Jahren mittlerweile,
manchmal haben wir auch in fremden Wohnungen gedreht.
Also es gibt so Wohnungen, die stellen die Leute, die dort wohnen, zur Verfügung in so einen Pool an Wohnungen,
so dass dann Produktionsfragen ... Du brauchst es nicht beschönigen, wir haben einfach in fremden Wohnungen, ungefragt in fremden Wohnungen gedreht. Und dann kriegt man ja so ein bisschen was von dem Wohnungsstil mit, so. Die räumen dann alles schön auf und so. Und dann hängt man da manchmal rum, weil Dreharbeiten sind immer zu 90 Prozent Warten. Und dann stand da auch so ein Bücherregal rum und manchmal hat man nichts zu tun. Und dann habe ich mir ein Bücherbuch geschnappt, und zwar so ein Geschichtsbuch aus den 70ern, also wirklich so eine ganze Reihe Geschichtsbücher, was die in der Schule gelernt haben, so von Steinzeit bis Zweiter Weltkrieg oder so.
Und dann habe ich mir als Zweiter Weltkrieg durchgelesen und habe in jeder Drehpause ein bisschen weitergelesen.
Und dann gibt es manchmal so unangenehme Smalltalks mit Komparsen und den anderen Darstellern.
Und dann kam so eine Komparsin auf mich zu und sagt, ah, was liest du denn da? Und ich so, ja, Zweiter Weltkrieg. Und sie so, ja, das hätte man sich auch sparen können, oder? Und ich dachte mir so, wow, ist das die subtilste historischste Einsicht, die wir hatten? Einfach so, ja, 60 Millionen Tote, ja, das hätt's auch nicht sein müssen, oder? Einfach wirklich so... Fragwürdig, also fast schon, was ist Ihre Meinung? Ich will Ihre Meinung dazu wissen. Ich find's geil, eine Meinung zu so einem historischen Ereignis zu haben, zu bewerten. Einfach so, ja, das war nix, oder? Oder? Aber vor allem, das sind dann die Momente, wo sie bestimmt, danach hat sie sich umgedreht und hat diesen, ich hab meinen Crush angesprochen und es es hat nicht funktioniert, diesen Augen-Zuknall-Blick, den man aus Highschool-Comedien kennt. Man hat gerade seinen Crush angesprochen, die auch Person, und dann hat sie sich verhaspelt und hat sich umgedreht und dann ... und hält dann so die beiden, die Bücher, die man hat, für den Unterricht, hält man so vor den Post. In den Ordner, ja, ja. Genau, mit so verschränkten Armen. Ich sag mal, in der Stephan-Tietze-Schule des Eisbrechens ist ja durchaus die Frage, was liest du da? Hat bei dir eine C-plus bekommen, glaube ich, oder?
Ja, C-plus, C-plus, drei plus meinst du. Ich habe ein weirdes Bewertungssystem. Dein Flirt-Ratgeber ist komplett in C-plus-plus geschrieben. Das ist ein bisschen verwirrend. Das sind Körbchengrössen, das ist halt ein bisschen fragwürdig. Also mein Eisbrecher-Stil ist schon eher Titanic, also schon eher am Eis zerbrechen. Schon mit der Rettungsweste an gehst du überhaupt hoher See. Wollen wir das? Ich habe immer, wenn man so Gruppen war, so Workshops oder so, haben die am Anfang gesagt, so jetzt machen wir ein paar Eisbrechen-Übungen. Dann dachte ich immer so, nee, Eis muss nicht gebrochen werden. Das ist so ein Eingreifen in die Natur, warum muss man Eis brechen? Ich meine, den ganzen Tag zeigt ihr irgendwie Szenen aus der Arktis, wo ein armer Eisbär auf einer Eisscholle ist, und jetzt soll man hier Eis brechen? Ich finde Eis gut, ich finde Eis nicht schlecht. Warum muss man Eis brechen? Du musst nicht mal alles brechen, du musst nicht mal alles in die Natur eingreifen. Jetzt auch viral gegangen, so ein bisschen Video mit eins zu eins, Video, wie die Titanic untergegangen ist, so real time. Weil weil es halt so ein paar Stunden dauert. Lass mich raten, es ist genau, wie man diesen billigen Comics kennt, einfach hat sich genau um neunzig Grad gedreht und ist dann gerade runtergegangen. Ja, als ob das wirklich so, woher weiss man, dass das so gesucht ist? Wie ist das passiert? Ja, die ist gegen einen Eisberg gefahren, Stefan. Ja, was war das Spannende an dem Video dann? Naja, dass es halt wirklich Realtime den Untergang zeigt. Wie lange dauert das Video? Keine Ahnung, drei Stunden oder so, je nachdem wie lange es halt gedauert hat. Wie lange es denn gedauert hat? Hast du keine Information daraus mitgenommen? Ja, halt jetzt kürzer als der Film, länger als der Film, aber ich sag mal, kürzer als so ein schöner Ausflug. Oder sowas in der Ecke. So kann man es einrahmen. Und es ist spannend, sich anzuschauen. Facebook ist so weird, oder nicht? Also mal ganz im Ernst, man geht doch auf Facebook morgens, um zu checken, wer hat Geburtstag. Irgendwie, guckt mal ein bisschen Bilder durchscrollen von Freunden, die man kennt, vielleicht mal ein lustiges, so einen lustigen Blog, den man abonniert hat, wo man irgendwie, weiss ich nicht, diese Hunderassen, keine Ahnung, sind besonders süss, sind besonders flauschig und klein und süss. Und hier sehen sie irgendwie lustige Bilder, wo Väter mit ihren Kindern lustige Sachen gemacht haben. Die Erde ist eine Scheibe. Genau, diese typischen Seiten, die man abonniert hat. Was war das gerade? Und dann ist man, das passiert immer häufiger, als ich morgens aufwache. Und dann war das erste Video, was bei Facebook war, war, Prank geht fürchterlich schief. Und dann guckt man sich das so an, es geht ja immer automatisch auch an, die Videos bei Facebook, ungefragt. Und dann war das einfach eine Freundin, die eine andere Freundin auf die Strasse schubst. Hat sie aber geschubst tatsächlich, ist auf die Strasse gefallen, es kam ein Bus und sie hat so schnell ihren Kopf bewegt, dass es gerade durch Millimeter an dem Tod vorbei ist. Dann ist sie wieder aufgestanden und hat mit ihrer Freundin gelacht. Und dann sind beide weitergegangen. Und ich sitze morgens, Kerzen gerade im Bett und denke mir, what the f, bin ich schweissgebadet, Puls auf 180 und musste diesen Prank mit angucken, wo mir dann Facebook, was ist mit dir eigentlich los? Das ist das Business, was du betreiben willst gerade? Aber der Prank war, dass sie so tut, als würde sie sie schubsen und hat sie dann tatsächlich geschubst. Nicht, der Prank war, ha, ich schubs sie auf die Strasse, oh, du bist fast gestorben. Wo ist er dann schiefgelaufen? Wollte sie ihn umbringen? Ich weiß nicht. Das war der eigentliche Prank. Wo ist der Prank denn schiefgelgelaufen? Ich weiß nicht genau, ich glaube, der Prank war, dass sie so tun wollte tatsächlich. Und dann hat sie sich wirklich geschubst und dann ist sie auch wirklich umgefallen. Haben die eigentlich den Motor ausgemacht bei der Titanic? Du kannst nicht genug von dem Thema bekommen? Weil ich meine, die haben ja diesen Eisberg so gestriffen seitlich. Dann hat die so die Seite aufgerissen. Sind nicht frontal drauf einfach. Nee, tatsächlich hat man rekonstruiert, wäre die Titanic frontal auf den Eisberg zugefahren, wäre sie nicht gesunken. Weil dann ist es irgendwie von der Statik besser und dann prallt es irgendwie ab. Ist auch Spitzenschiff vorne. Ist auch spitz. Ja genau, dann dotzt es halt so dagegen, weil das wie so ein Ei von oben hat ja mehr Kraft, hält mehr aus. Deswegen sagt man ja auch, es ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs. Ja, aber da haben die ja so gestriffen und dann müssen ja noch weiter gefahren sein und dann haben die dann irgendwann gesagt soll stopp jetzt erst mal haben die es gemerkt also haben den aufprall am schiff gemerkt das war da haben die kerze die kronleuchter gezittert und die band ist so einmal umgekippt oder was die die haben auch versucht zu bremsen glaube ich oder die haben noch mal volle kraft zurück und dann während des untergangs hat einer gesagt, jetzt mach mein Motor aus, das wird nicht so dumm. Leute, das war's. Hä? Komm, mir eine Schaufel noch. Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen. Das ist wirklich, das ist eines der most unrelatable Filme. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, so saß ich auch im Kino. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, sie mal so auf so einem Schiff zu wesen. So kalt ist das nicht, ich war auch schon im Meer. Aber du hast doch mal von Piloten erzählt, dass sie nichts wissen, dass sie dumm sind. Ja, übrigens die Storyline geht weiter. Wir sind immer noch in der Gegendarstellung. Der Kollege kam neulich ins Büro und meinte, ja, wir alle so und wie laufen deine Prüfungen, weil er kam dann auch deswegen zu spät und dann meinte er, ja, ich bin nur durch einer durchgefallen und vier von fünf habe ich jetzt bestanden.
Aber ich dachte wieder, das kann nicht dein Ernst sein,
du kannst doch nicht durchfallen bei einer Prüfung.
Aber man hat sechs Versuche für eine fucking Prüfung als Pilot.
Warum gerade sechs Versuche? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also ich kann zwei Versuche verstehen, dass man sagt, okay, keine Ahnung, war nicht so gut drauf.
So strange.
Aber sechs, dass man sagt, kein siebtes Mal.
Und Kollege, jetzt aber raus! Es sind mindestens vier zu viel bei einem Piloten. Der muss funktionieren, das sind Übermenschen. Aber genauso denke ich mir auch, gibt es sowas auch auf dem Schiff? Auch. Also dass die dann irgendwie, oh jetzt diese Lampe brennt, Buch auf, nachgucken. Gibt es da so ein Protokoll, was passiert, wenn das Schiff sinkt? Dann mal sagen, okay. Gegen Eisberg vor allem, sehr konkret, das ist ein konkreter Fall. Das Drehbuch kommt im Drehbuch des Films einfach.
Sind Sie gegen Eisberg gefallen?
Aber dann so, macht man dann so Autoradio aus, Motor aus, Licht aus, jetzt geht das Schiff unter. Erstmal Radio aus, erst mal, wenn man rückwärts einparkt, erst mal Radio aus. Niemand will den dummen Jazz-FM hören, während das scheiß Schiff untergeht, ja. Untergehen drei Stunden lang, ja, aber Free Jazz, nope. Erstmal Grönland 2 aus. Unfassbar nerviger Sender, die ganze Zeit, Inuit. Ein Unfall auf der Acht, ja, wir wissen's, aber ich mein... Und ich werde da vorher gesagt, Schnee, das war so leider vorher gesagt. Weil das ist ja so nach oben gegangen, wenn da der Motor weitergegangen wäre, dann hätte er so in der Luft gedreht, das hätte so total albern ausgesehen, du kannst ja nicht sterben, während er so... Hä? Aber dann ist es seitlich umgekippt oder was? Nee, es ist in der Mitte auseinandergebrochen und dann haben beide Enden nach oben geschaut und dann sind die, ähnlich wie die World Trade Center, muss man an der Stelle auch mal sagen, stellen die sich erst so auf und klappen dann so auf. Titanic was an Inside Job! Aber das gibt es auch manchmal so, alles reimt sich, hat auch George Lucas gesagt, also reimt sich auch Titanic auf World Trade Center. Ja, George Lucas ist ein Vollidiot. Titanic ist ein Icebergjob. Ja, finde ich gut. Hau raus, in die Welt hinaus. Nee, bei Twitter bin ich irgendwie ausgestiegen. Apropos Gegendarstellung, viele Nachrichten, ist nicht wirklich eine Gegendarstellung, ich schleiche es einfach mal zur Reihe, Kuckusei. Viele Nachrichten haben uns ereilt, dass jetzt schon langsam, Stefan, ich hoffe, du bist dir dessen bewusst, deine Probezeit für die Matratze zu Ende ist. Nervigste Podcast-UFO-Aktion aller Zeiten. Absolut, ja. Vor allem, wenn du das schon sagst, und du warst nicht in jedem Menschen drin, neben Tweet, wo mein Name Ad gementioned wurde.
Alter, Dankeschön. Also es hat funktioniert, Leute haben darauf reagiert, ich habe heute mindestens 120 Nachrichten bekommen, allein bei Twitter habe ich heute, das war lächerlich, morgen läuft es aus, ich habe heute noch einen Tag. Tatsächlich, viele widersprechen sich, viele haben an anderen Tagen angefangen, viele haben mir schon vor einer Woche geschrieben, danke dafür, sehr fürsorglich. Es ist, 100 zu zählen ist nicht so leicht.
Aber viele haben auch letzte Woche geschrieben, du musst in nächster Woche die zurückgeben. Das wäre auch wiederum cool. Die, die letzte Woche geschrieben haben, du hast noch einen Tag, danke schon trotzdem an euch. Vor allem ist es ja immer so unfair mit so Online-Aufrufen, weil man immer sagt, hey, gebt uns Bescheid. Und die ersten zwei, die uns Bescheid geben, hey cool, vielen Dank, und ab dann nervt's. Ab dann nervt's. Aber die Leute wissen ja nicht, dass sie nerven, weil für die macht es ja keinen Unterschied, ob sie jetzt die Ersten sind oder die Hundertsten, das wissen sie ja nicht. Aber danke für die vielen, vielen Nachrichten. Das heißt, viele sagen, hey, ich wollte euch nur erinnern, und so, ja, wir wissen's. Obwohl er einfach nichts dazu wissen kann. Aber Stefan, jetzt mal ganz kurz Resümee, nach 198 Tagen. Genau, jetzt wird nämlich die Aktion noch unnützer gemacht. Ja, ich fand dich schon eigentlich nach zwei ziemlich gut. Ja? Du bist zufrieden? Ja, ich war sehr schnell, wo war ich mir klar darüber, dass ich die behalten möchte. Ja, super Matratze. Also es wird wirklich, ich kann mir vorstellen, warum es den Titel Beste jemals getestete Matratze bekommen hat. Angenommen, du würdest die jetzt morgen noch zurückbringen in den Laden. Wie viele Orangensaftflecken sind jetzt da drauf mittlerweile auf der Matratze? Milchflecken. Milchflecken. Ein paar Milchflecken sind drauf. Entschuldigung für die Milchflecken. Aber nee, ist noch relativ sauber. Ja? Ja. Relativ unbenutzt. Isst du im Bett? Trinkst du im Bett? Ja. Trinkst du dich in den Schlaf? Nee, ihr müsst euch vorstellen, ich schlafe oft mit so einem Berg Chicken Wings auf meinem Bauch ein. Das kennt ja jeder, mit so einem Eimer neben sich, der irgendwann so umfällt. Und so ein Bier in der Hand, was irgendwann so um zwei Uhr nachts, die Hand schläfst dann irgendwann ein. Und das Bier läuft in die Zigarette? Und das Bier läuft in die nische Zigarette? Gott sei Dank. Gott sei Dank. Oh, muss man sagen. Minus mal minus erg ergibt mal wieder Plus. Aber das war es jetzt auch, glaube ich, mit den Richtigstellungen,
oder? Können wir einfach aufhören jetzt,
können wir aufhören mit langfristigen Aktionen,
keine langfristigen Aktionen mehr, erst mal das
und keine Quatsch mehr. Das war
unsere Rubrik. Sorry!
Sorry, große Sorry-Gegendarstellung.
Kommen wir jetzt zur nächsten, lang
angekündigten Aktion, und ich bin sehr gespannt,
denn Stefan Tietz hat uns heute was mitgebracht. Es ist wirklich, sie sind da. Ich sag nur so viel, sie sind da. Meine 23andMe DNA-Ergebnisse sind da. Sie sind da. Und ich muss mich einloggen, ich habe mein Passwort vergessen. Stefan wurde analysiert. Stefan muss man sagen, hat sein gesamtes Haupthaar in einen Schuhkarton getan und an eine zwieligte Firma, kanadische Firma geschickt, damit seine DNA analysiert wird. Und ich bin sehr gespannt. Also, es ist zu viel für eine Folge. Ich habe schon mal reingeguckt, weil ich musste mich darauf vorbereiten, um es nicht komplett überfordert zu sein, weil du wirst zugeballert mit Daten. Die schicken dir sogar so eine Mail nach einem Tag, nachdem du die Ergebnisse bekommen hast, und hey, ist alles okay bei dir? Wir wissen oft, dass dich diese Ergebnisse überfordern können. Hast du Fragen? Hier ist eine Nummer. Also die sind schon sehr, die sind sehr pushy und sehr fürsorglich. Aber ganz kurz, jetzt noch mal ganz kurz für alle, die jetzt vielleicht nicht so ganz auf dem Dach sind. Also die Idee ist, es gibt eine Firma, da kann man, da bekommt man ein Rohr geschickt, da muss man reinspucken, da muss man Wasser, was da drin ist, reinmachen, zu konservieren, man muss es denen zurückschicken, das geht ja bei den Niederlanden in Deutschland, und dann bekommen die das und werten das aus, die werten deine DNA aus und die finden so heraus, wie, und jetzt haben die quasi sehr viele DNA-Proben auf der Welt genommen und die finden heraus, wo Leute leben, die eine ähnliche DNA haben wie du. Das war ja auch die Frage. Man kann ja nicht, es gibt nicht gute, es gibt, man kann das gut zurückverfolgen, wo mein DNA-Stamm herkommt und so und da gibt es auch spannende, sehr spannende Sachen, ich sage nur so viel, denn die Andertaler ist irgendwo auch noch ein bisschen in mir drin. Moment mal, ganz kurz. Das heisst, die können aber nur deine DNA vergleichen mit der DNA der Bevölkerung, die es jetzt aktuell dort gibt.
Genau, so habe ich das verstanden. Ich habe für Fragen aber auch noch einen Joker in der Hinterhand. Wir haben einen Telefonjoker heute.
Wir haben Biologie-Masterstudenten in der Hinterhand theoretisch. Den können wir anrufen bei dringenden Fragen.
Das heisst, noch mal ganz kurz, bevor wir jetzt einsteigen in die Materie, ganz kurz nochmal zusammenfassen. Was ist DNA?
Das würdest du vorbereiten. Das war dein Referat. Nee, ich hab... Wie, du hast nicht DNA? Scheiße, DNA. Ich hab Chomosomen. Warum hast du nicht DNA? Ich hab Allele. Nicht Allele! Ich hab mir ganzes Album angehört. Adele. Wie? Ich dachte Adele. Fuck, Mann, ey. Scheiße, ich bin komplett blank, sorry. Ja, ja, null Punkte. Also DNA sind. Wie viele Chromosome hat der Mensch? Desoxybronukleinsäure. Aber also ich kenne mehrere Begriffe, DNA, Chromosom, Gen, Allel. Das sind alle vier Begriffe, die ich kenne. Wie hängen die zusammen? Alles klar, ich dachte, wir müssen den später aktivieren. Wir rufen jetzt Steven an. Das ging schnell, der wird sich wundern. Den rufen wir jetzt an. Ich finde es vor allem auch gut, wie du innerhalb von einer Folge meine Biologie-Experte Charlotte einfach mal straight gefeuert hast und ersetzt hast durch deinen eigenen Biologie-Experten.
Ja, aber bei dir weiss man ja nicht, wo du die mal anschleppst. Und dann mittlerweile auch die Angst, dass du irgendwann Leute erfindest, damit die dir zustimmen.
Oh, so Schatten-Experten. Ja, so Leuten sagst, ich weiss, du hast keine Ahnung davon, wir werden dir eine Frage stellen von irgendwelchen komischen Pflanzen, die andere Pflanzen annehmen.
Sag einfach, ich habe Recht. Sag einfach, ich, Florentin, habe Recht, Stefan, der andere, Unrecht. Okay. Quatsch. Ich will nicht mal. Wir müssen gleich, also es gibt sehr viel zu erzählen. Also gleich wird's gut? Gleich wird's gut. Jesus fucking Christ! Okay. Tja, Charlotte ist verfügbar. Charlotte ist erreichbar, immer zur Stelle. Wer ist das? Steven, Schulkollege. Ach Gott, jetzt kommen die scheiß Bandkollegen einmal wieder. Hallo, wo? Hey, Steven, grüßt dich, der Stefan hier und der Florentin. Hi Steven, du bist live im Podcast-Ufo, ist das okay für dich? Das ist super. Ich habe dich ja schon vorgewarnt. Und zwar, wir wollten eigentlich dich ja später anrufen, wenn wir wirklich in Detailfragen kommen, aber wir sind jetzt schon überfordert. Kannst du uns genau erklären, was ist DNA und was genau sagt das über mich aus? Und du hast mir damals ja schon eine Nachricht geschrieben, als ich davon erzählt habe. Was genau machen diese Unternehmen? Diese Fragen kamen wir an dich. Also was ist DNA? DNA speichert eine Erbinformation, also quasi alles, was sich ausmacht, alle Gene, dann aufgebaut aus vier Basen. Wie viele Gene? Wie viele Gene? Ja. Wie viele Chromosome, hat man noch irgendwie 46 oder so, 23? Du hast 22 Autosomen, also das, was alles so ausmacht, und dann noch ein Geschäftschromosom, und das quasi in zwei Kopien, also du hast insgesamt 46 Kopien.
Deswegen heißt die Firma 23 und 23.
Genau.
Und wie viele Gene sind in den Chromosomen? Wie viele Gene sind in den Chromosomen? Macht die Frage Sinn? Bei Menschen, wie viele Gene auf den Chromosomen sind, das ist eine gute Frage. Das weiß ich aus dem Zielgreif. Was machst du nochmal genau? Du machst einen Master in Biologie, oder? Ja, ich mache Biologie, aber auch eher Pflanzen. Alle Pflanzen, Leute. Pflanzen sind so langweilig. Aber hast du die Folge gehört, wo wir über diese Pflanze gesprochen haben? Wir haben ja neulich über die Pflanze gesprochen, die plötzlich die DNA von anderen Pflanzen annehmen. Nein, nicht die DNA, nur das Aussehen des Blatts. Ach genau, das war ja nicht so spannend. Das habe ich gehört. Und großer Quatsch, ne grosser Quatsch, grosser Hoax, Clickbait. Weiß nicht, habe ich mir nicht genau angeguckt, aber es sind übrigens 21.000 Gene. 21.000 Gene, alles klar. Pro Chromosom oder insgesamt? Insgesamt wahrscheinlich. Das sind alle Gene, die für Proteine kodieren, aber es gibt halt auch noch Gene, die nicht unbedingt für Gene kodieren,
aber das würde jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen zu weit kommen, das alles im Detail auszuführen. Okay, und diese Seite, die untersucht jetzt meine DNA und das vergleicht die mit Menschen, die jetzt gerade in den anderen Ländern leben? Also die, ähm, die erfreieren halt eine DNA und dann packen sie das auch so, die nennen sie Genotyping-Chips quasi, und die zeigen dann an, wo du quasi Variationen hast in deiner DNA. Das heisst, diese Variation werden Snips genannt, Single-Nucleotide-Polymorphism, und und die können variieren diese Stellen zwischen verschiedenen Menschen. Und eigentlich sind 99,5 % oder so aller, der ganzen DNA ist gleich, aber es gibt halt diese Single Nucleotide Polymorphism, die jetzt nicht um den gleich sind und wo dann halt die Unterschiede herkommen. Okay, und das vergleichen die mit Menschen, die jetzt gerade irgendwo leben und nicht mit Menschen, nicht mit dem Ötzi? Nee, nee, nee, das ist halt genau das Ding. Ich glaube, die sagen sogar auf ihrer Seite genau das. Es gab zum Beispiel vor ein paar Jahren dieses zuhause Genome Project, da wurden halt auch von der ganzen Welt tausend verschiedene Menschen sequenziert und da halt geguckt, wo halt da Unterschiede sind. Aber das ist halt genau so, wenn bei dir zum Beispiel rausgekommen ist, du bist, keine Ahnung, 60 Prozent, also du hast vielleicht mal den Abend mit Deutschen, dann ist es halt für Deutschen, die jetzt leben und nicht von vor keinem anderen Jahren. Oder wenn bei dir rauskommt, du bist irgendwie was anderes, dann heißt das, dass du, du hast Ähnlichkeiten mit Leuten, die dort gerade wohnen, was dann halt heißt, dass ihr irgendwo vermutlich einen Common Ancestor habt.
Und wie gross ist so ein Gen?
Aber wie weit er zurückliegt?
Also ist es so im atomaren Molekularbereich oder ist es wie so eine Zelle?
Florian fragt, wie gross so ein Gen ist. so eine Zelle oder wie gross ist so ein Gen? Florian fragt, wie gross so ein Gen ist.
Ein Gen?
Ja, wie gross ist so ein Gen?
Ist es wie gross...
Das kann... das ist halt schwierig zu sagen. Also Gene, die grössere Gen wird halt in Basenphasen gemessen.
Aber ist es eher so in der Grössenordnung Molekül oder Grössenordnung Sandkorn? Eher so Sandkorn, eher so... Gute Frage. Also eine Base besteht da schon aus minderem Atom. Also da ist halt Zucker dran und das Barensehen und dann das Phosphatrückgrat und so. Und das ist halt relativ... Also es ist halt größer als Atom, es ist halt schon ein relativ großes Molekül. Okay, okay. Und wie viele Baren genau eigentlich haben, hat halt ganz, ganz viele verschiedene, also hat abhängig von Nachteil und verschiedenen Dingen. Alles klar. Okay, ich glaube, wir sind erstmal gut aufgestellt. Wir werden uns gleich nochmal anrufen, wenn wir irgendwelche Fragen haben, aber ich glaube, wir kommen erstmal klar. Ich hätte noch ganz, ganz eine Frage. Ja aber also man hat jetzt nicht verstanden hat man denn verstanden wie diese gene funktionieren
oder als zum beispiel keine ahnung so krankheiten wie alzheimer oder so merkt man einfach alle
die alzheimer haben haben diese art von genkonstellation oder oder weiß man warum gewisse
gene jetzt alzheimer auslösen oder guckt man sich einfach nur an was da ist. Kommt man jetzt so Rassentheorie in so einem Quatsch? Also, ich denke, bei Menschen hat man schon bei sehr, sehr vielen Genen eine sehr gute Ahnung, was die halt machen und welche Wege die halt drin sind, ob irgendwie ein Gen eher mit einer Verdauung zu tun hat, also für Genkodier, die eher mit einer Verdauung zu tun haben oder eher für Kanal-Märchen-Prozesse oder so. Aber ich glaube gerade bei Alzheimer ist halt das Schwierige, dass man halt nicht genau weiss, welche Gene das sind. Und da ist dann vermutlich die, also alles ist vermutlich im Gen-Ursprung, aber welche Gene und warum und ob es jetzt vielleicht nur so ein Single-Nukleotide-Polymophilien ist oder vielleicht was ganz, ganz anderes ganz, ganz anderes. Also soweit ich weiß, ist das noch nicht so ganz herausgefunden. Okay, alles klar. Viel Erfolg dabei. Ja, viel Erfolg bei dem, was du machst. Wo rufe ich gerade an? Das ist sauteuer, weil du gerade in Schweden bist, oder? Ich bin gerade in Schweden. Alles klar, gut, das hätte ich vorher vielleicht auch nochmal checken müssen. Alles klar, vielen, vielen Dank, Steven. Dann melden wir uns gleich nochmal, wenn wir Fragen haben. Ansonsten vielen Dank schon mal. Dankeschön, tschüss. Danke, Steven. So, jetzt bin ich aber sehr gespannt. So, wir fangen erst mal, also wir heben uns ein paar Sachen auch noch für andere Folgen auf. Okay. Aber ich kann schon sagen, sowas wie bist du sportlich und so, in diese Richtung geht es tatsächlich auch. Ernsthaft?en, machen wir gleich, weil die vergleichen mit Leuten, die eine ähnliche DNA haben, du kannst dann so Fragebögen ausfüllen und dann sagen Leute, die eine ähnliche DNA haben wie du, mit denen wirst du dann verglichen in den Topf geworfen und dann sagen die, wie die auf diese Fragen gar nicht getragen.
Das ist eine reine statistische Überschneidung.
Reine statistische Überschneidung, mega interessant.
Also, musst du das auch ausfüllen, musst du auch schreiben, ich habe auch alles ausgefüllt, was ich ausfüllen konnte.
Bist du sportlich, ja oder nein? Ja, habe ich alles schon gemacht. Diese ganzen Fragebgebühren habe ich alles schon ausgefüllt. Hast du es reingeschrieben? Nicht sportlich. So, also was glaubst du erstmal? Also ich kann, also es ist ungefähr, es wird grob in Länder und Kontinente eingeteilt, ich sag mal so, nicht so überraschend, nicht so mega überraschend, also es ist schon sehr eindeutig. Ja, dann Spanien. Spanien, tatsächlich ist Iberian, ich bin zu zwei Prozent iberisch. Ist das viel oder wenig? Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube wenig. Aber also wie groß ist denn der grösste Anteil? 40 Prozent. 42,2 Prozent. 42,2 Prozent deutsch, wie wir sagen. Ich bin 100 Prozent europäisch, schau mal. 100 Prozent? 100 Prozent europäisch. Knallhaar Europäer. Da ist doch immer ein bisschen Mongole drin. Nirgendwo Mongole drin. Klar. Null Mongole, kein Mongole. Es wurde alles getestet, aber ich bin kein Mongole. Ah gut, also der aktuellen Bevölkerung. Ja, aber auch das könntest du ja gut zurückverfolgen, weil die haben ja dann auch tendenziell, kannst du ja auch zurückverfolgen, hat er es eben gerade erklärt. Auch die aktuelle Bevölkerung wird ja zurückverfolgt, woher die kommen. Aber 0% mongolisch, ich bin zu 42,2% deutsch-französisch, 42,2% deutsch-französisch, zu 25,8% osteuropäisch, hier wurde speziell Polen genannt. Zu 5 Prozent ... Ganz kurz, 25 Prozent polnisch. 25,8 Prozent Polen. Ostdeutschland. Also das heißt, kann man jetzt sagen, dass einer deiner Grosseltern da herkommt? Oder was genau sagt uns das jetzt? Das sagt aus. Da kann man irgendwo ... Also hast du denn osteuropäische Verwandte, weißt du das? Nee, weiß ich nicht. Es kann sein, dass ein Urgross-Opa von mir theoretisch aus dem Bereich Schlesien und so kommen könnte. Das kann sein. We predict you had ancestors that lived in Poland within the last 200 years. Das ist krass. Das ist schon interessant einfach alles.
Ja.
Okay, fünf Prozent britisch und irisch, aber da sagen sie nicht woher, und zwei Prozent iberisch, ein Prozent skandinavisch, 0,5 Prozent Balkan, insgesamt sind das 21,5 Prozent aus dem nordwestlichen Bereich Europas, 0,3 Prozent aus dem südlichen Bereich Europas, 1,8 broadly European, wo man nicht genau zuordnen kann, aber ich bin auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr deutsch, tatsächlich. You most likely had a parent in Germany. Herr Tietze. Wahnsinn. Grandparent or great-grandparent in Osteuropa. An Nazi gehen hast du Nazis drin? Ja, ich habe überall Hakenkreuze, sehe die gerade nicht, aber tatsächlich hier, also you most likely had a grandparent, great-grandparent or second-great-grandparent who was 100% Eastern European. Was ist second-great-parent? Zweiter Opa? Ur-Ur-Opa. Ach so, dann hoch zwei. Hoch zwei. Ur-Ur-Opa. Sagt man das so? Second Great Parent. Genau. Und you most likely had a second Great Parent who was 100% British. Oh! Und iberisch. A third Great Parent von der iberischen Halbinsel. Und das muss ich sagen, merke ich. Auf der Tanzfläche, da kommen dann nachts meine zwei Prozent, gerade nach so einem Tequilachen, kommen dann meine zwei Prozent Spanier raus. Aber hat dich das denn beeinflusst, jetzt wo du das so weißt? Also lebst du jetzt anders? Ich spreche jetzt fließend Spanisch, fließend mega gut Englisch und sehr gut Französisch. Aber hast du erwartet, oder? Habe ich erwartet, ja. Ich hatte gehofft, weniger Osteuropa, aber da kann man sich ja nicht aussuchen. Man kann sich die Familie ja nicht aussuchen. Aber jetzt wird doch wieder deine DNA als Grundlage genommen für Deutscher. Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendjemand in der Ukraine den DNA-Test macht und er hat eine ähnliche DNA wie du, dann sagt man dem, ja, du bist Deutscher wegen Stefan Tietze.
Aber du bist ja wieder nur zu 40 Prozent.
Genau.
Das ist jetzt kompliziert.
Stell keine Detailfragen, bitte.
Für nirgendwo hin.
Was ich sehr spannend finde, sind meine Neandertaler-Vorfahren.
Was viele nicht wissen, es wurde herausgefunden, meine ich, dass der Mensch nicht leicht vom Neandertaler abstand. Nur manche Menschen. Ja, es gibt auch den Homo sapiens und der kommt eigentlich nicht vom Neandertaler, sonst der Neandertal ist so eine, der ist irgendwo ausgestorben, der Neandertaler. Irgendwann gab es halt einen gemeinsamen Vorfahren, nehme ich an, und dann ist der Homo sapiens entstanden und der Neandertaler. Der Neandertaler ist ausgestorben. Genau, und ich habe 282 Neandertaler-Variationen in meiner DNA.
Das heißt Gene? Nee, in den Genen sind Variationen, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht. Okay. Kann ja nicht sein, weil man hat ja nur 46 Chromosome. Aber er hat 20.000 Gene. Ja, genau, stimmt, ja richtig. Fächtig gut. Aber ich habe 282 Neandertaler-Chromosome-Variation. Das sind 57 mehr, 57 Prozent mehr, äh, nee, das sind mehr als 57 Prozent aller Kunden dieses Programms.
Also ich habe mehr Neandertaler in mir als 57 Prozent von 23 and 1.
Gut, aber mehr als die Hälfte, ist das so viel?
Weiß ich nicht, ist glaube ich nicht so viel.
Wie viele Huhn?
Aber jetzt kommt das Beste.
Tatsächlich wird dann angezeigt, welches Chromosom davon kommt. Woher diese Neandertal, wo diese Variationen drin sind und was die an mir auslösen. Ah, okay. Also welche deiner Eigenschaften sind neandertalisch? Genau. Und meine Variationen erheben zum Beispiel sowas wie gerades Haar, straight hair, less likely to sneeze after eating dark chocolate. Und da muss ich... Ja, die andere Teile, deswegen sind sie ausgestorben. Grösse zum Beispiel, also Leute sind kleiner, die vom anderen Teile abstammen. Echt? Bei mir offensichtlich nicht. Aber bei mir ist less back hair, weniger Rückenhaare. Und ich habe kaum Rückenhaare. Und das ist wegen, weil diese Genvarianten neandertalisch sind. Genau, die Genvarianten, die bei mir überlebt haben, die vom Neandertaler stammen, sorgen dafür, dass ich kaum Rückenhaare habe. Und ich finde, das ist das Praktischste, was man haben will. Das stimmt. Das ist mega praktisch. Bei den Neandertalen haben wir oft irgendwie so in so Freizeitbädern sind die die oft die Rutschen runtergerutscht und dann war es natürlich schlecht, wenn man Haare hat, weil das natürlich dann sind, die konnten die nicht so flitzen und deswegen hat sich die Haare am sich zu verliehen. Aber sind wir mal kurz ehrlich, als ich gesehen habe, ich habe eine Yannertaler-Variation in mir, dachte ich kurz, ah shit, weil man will, man verbindet die automatisch mit, also mit wenig Intellekt. Naja, die haben verloren. Die haben verloren, die haben auch rausgestorben. Niemand sagte, dass der Schlechtere immer verlieren muss. Aber dass ausgerechnet das weniger Rückenhaar die Variation emittet, das fand ich schon gut. Das fand ich nicht schlecht. Nicht schlecht. Ja. Jetzt wird es damit sehr interessant, da gibt es die Gruppe, die aus Afrika hervorgekommen ist, die dann den Menschennehmer gebildet hat, nennt man sozusagen Haplogroup, und die ist von meiner Mutter, haben die gesagt, sehr selten. Und zwar, ich bin einer von 16.000, der aus der J1 kommt. J1 ist eine, die unten aus Südostafrika hochgekommen ist. Es wird sehr interessant, finde ich, für mich, wahrscheinlich für euch nicht so, aber jetzt wird es spannend, wo aus der Wiege der Menschen heute Afrika quasi meine Gruppe zuerst kam. Und wie viele Menschen gab es damals? Also deine Gruppe gab es 16.000. Nee, ich bin einer von 16.000 der Welt. Also prozentual bin ich einer von 16.000.
Ach so, okay, verstehe.
Also in Prozenten bin ich, sehr wenige sind so.
Und die haben gelebt 27.000 Jahre von jetzt aus.
Abgefahren.
Das ist interessant, die haben die Eiszeit überlebt und so ein Kram.
Haben wir noch nicht.
Aber haben nicht alle unsere Vorfahren die Eiszeit überlebt?
Ja, weiß nicht.
Hat mich schon gefreut. So, und jetzt kann man
hier auf Your DNA Family gehen.
Und jetzt siehst du genau,
wie dein DNA
aufgebaut ist und deine DNA
Family, wie das Breakdown, da wird sehr viel
geladen gerade schon. Also es ist wirklich
abgefahren.
Tatsächlich sieht man auch, wo in Amerika
Leute mit meiner DNA leben. Und zu 60 Prozent leben die in Kalifornien. Das heißt, da könntest du alte Verwandte finden. Also wenn in Kalifornien, ja. Lauf mal durch die Strasse und frag mal Leute. So, und jetzt steht hier. Jetzt hat 23andMe meine DNA-Relatives gefunden. Leute, die eine ähnliche DNA haben. Und jetzt gibt es so Fun-Facts über sich. Also 48% dieser Leute sind less likely to have learned a foreign language as an adult. Okay, dann toll. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das... 46% more likely to think that fresh cilantro tastes like soap. Was ist cilantro? Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen vorher. Cilantro. Koriander. Wie kommt man denn auf solche Fakten? Koriander schmeckt wie Seife. Und ich bin 46 Prozent wahrscheinlicher, schmecke ich Koriander wie Seife. Aber das ist gar keine subjektive Einschätzung, oder wie, sondern deine Geschmacksknospen sind so ausgedreht, dass diese Geschmäcker gleich schließen. 45% less likely to be a vegetarian. Und das habe ich auch. What? Ja, aber die Entscheidung trifft man doch. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob die einfach noch sagen. Ja, einfach statistisch dann. Statistisch gesehen. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das auf DNA zurück, aber ich kenne die Fleischversorgung, wie sehr man darauf etwas mag, weiß ich nicht. 44% less likely to have red body or facial hair, okay. 38% less likely to drink instant coffee. Trinkst du instant coffee? Nee. Ja, okay. Wissenschaft. 34% less likely to have perfect pitch, also ähm. Aha, absolutes Gehör. Absolutes Gehör, ja, habe ich nicht. 34% more likely to have perfect pitch, also ähm, aha, absolutes Gehör, absolutes Gehör, ja, habe ich nicht, 34% more likely to have sweaty feet, ich glaube die wollen nicht beleidigen, Stefan, ich glaube das ist einfach nur eine lange Liste an Beleidigungen, und das, ah krass, das habe ich nämlich irgendwie schon mal gewusst, 21% more likely to own a dog, und ich habe diesen Wunsch in mir, ein Hund, ich weiß nicht woher er kommt, ein Tier zu besitzen, ein Hund, ein Hund, 18% more likely to own a dog. Und ich habe diesen Wunsch in mir, ein Hund, ich weiß nicht, woher kommt, ein Tier zu besitzen.
Ein Hund!
18% more likely to own a cat.
Wie, Katze und Hund?
Ja, 18% more likely to own a cat, 21% Hund.
Also an Kopf und Kopf und rennen.
Ja, an Kopf und rennen.
Schnauze an Schnauze rennen.
Leute, ich muss auch noch ein bisschen kommentieren.
Ich muss auch noch ein bisschen reinstreuen.
16% less likely to be able to do a backbend kickover. Das ist diese, wenn man ein Rad, ein Rad schlagen. Kann ich nicht, kann ich auch nicht. Das ist Wahnsinn, Wissenschaft! Thirteen percent is more likely to be able to wiggle their ears. Kann ich. Nee, das ist ja gar nichts.
Du guckst einfach nur den Mund auf.
Ich guck angestrengt.
Du machst einfach nur den Mund auf.
Ich guck, ist ja angestrengt.
Nicht schlecht, das ist der Wette der Welt.
Ten percent more likely to be a Supertaster.
Okay, ich habe Superstar gelesen zuerst.
Supertaster.
Ich habe Superstar gelesen.
Ten percent more likely to be a Supertaster. Bist du ein Supertaster? Ja, ich bin offensichtlich Supertaster. Ich habe Superstar gelesen. Tempest in Wall, du bist Supertaster. Bist du ein Supertaster? Ja, ich bin offensichtlich Supertaster. Aber schmeckst du gut oder schmeckst du gut? Nein, ich weiß nicht genau. Ich kann gut schmecken. Ich schmecke sehr intensiv, weißt du es oder was. Am Mann aber ist mit der Have Learned Foreign Language. Warum weißt du das, dass du intensiv schmeckst? Glaube ich. Du hast ja keinen Vergleich. Es ist Referenz. Es ist so interessant. Ich dachte, das ist ein bisschen übersichtlich. Es ist sehr viel, du kannst sehr viel nachgucken über dich selbst. Aber ich glaube, wir haben auf jeden Fall schon was gedeckt. Aber gibt es da auch so krasse Sachen wie Krankheit oder so? Welche Krankheiten noch kreis? Krankheiten machen die echt extra nicht, das haben die auch früher geschrieben. Weil da wollen die halt nicht keine Verantwortung für übernehmen. Das ist wirklich spannend.
Also ich muss das nochmal vernünftig aufbereiten.
Ein paar Sachen habe ich gerade auch noch überrascht, die man hier vorher nicht so gesehen hat.
Aber ich will das nochmal aufbereiten und dann vernünftig, dass man präsentieren, so ein paar Sachen nochmal.
Sehr spannend.
Aber es ist sehr zu empfehlen. Es kräftet 100 Euro tatsächlich, das ist sehr viel.
Aber ich finde, man lernt sehr viel über sich, gerade wenn ihr Biologie interessiert seid oder Wissenschaftsinter seid, dann macht das mal über euch, super spannend. Krass. Mach du das mal. Ah, ich weiß nicht, ich habe Angst. Locker 10% Spanisch. Ja? Sieh. Sehr interessant. Ich glaube, heute ist so ein bisschen die Wissenschaftsfolge, oder? Kann es sein? Du hast gerade so ein bisschen die Naturwissenschaftliche Komponente reingebracht, ich würde gerne ein bisschen was Geisteswissenschaftliches reinbringen. Okay, ja, bringe was rein. Denn vor einiger Zeit hat uns eine E-Mail erreicht und da hat uns eine Studentin gefragt, hey, habt ihr Bock, ein paar Fragen zu beantworten zu eurem Podcast, weil ich schreibe gerade eine Hausarbeit über euren Podcast. Und das ist so, als wir hier vor vier Jahren angefangen haben, mit unseren Hüten, wo so Propeller drauf waren, drauf dachten wir, ach, eines Tages mal. Das war immer so ein Gag. So eine wissenschaftliche Analyse. Den Gag haben wir bestimmt auch mal gemacht sogar im Podcast. Ich habe tatsächlich mal so einen Autoren von Seinfeld, da hat jemand mal eine Doktorarbeit geschrieben über den Humor in Seinfeld. Also wirklich richtig umfangreich. Und da hat er dann wirklich so, ich glaube, 21 verschiedene Arten von Gags innerhalb von Seinfeld, so aufgedröselt, die Mechanik genau analysiert. Mega gut, mega gut. Und dann hat er irgendwann auch an diesen Writers Room geschickt. Und die hatten es halt so als Running Gag, dass immer wenn jemand einen Gag pitcht, dann so, Moment, wir müssen erst kurz nachgucken, ob das in unsere Sendung passt. Und hatten halt immer den Gag, diese Bibel, wo alles über sie drinsteht, aber sie selbst haben das natürlich nicht so gesehen, so dass sie konnten damit nicht so wahnsinnig viel anfangen, aber halt total spannend, irgendwas von außen zu sehen. Und deswegen war es natürlich auch mein Wunsch von uns, so eine äussere Analyse zu bekommen. Ja, und ich habe es verschlungen. Also ich habe das wirklich, ich habe noch nie eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit so verschlungen wie diese. Und ich war auch noch nie so unangenehm berührt von einer wissenschaftlichen Arbeit wie bei dieser.
Und tatsächlich, es ist geschehen,
sie ist fertig geworden mit ihrer, ich glaube,
es ist eine Hausarbeit, ich kenne mich nicht so gut aus mit
Studium und so. Was ist eine Hausarbeit?
Ich glaube, es ist eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit, auf jeden Fall
kriegt sie dafür eine Note. Aber es ist keine Bachelorarbeit.
Nein, es ist nicht die Bachelorarbeit, es ist nicht die Abschlussarbeit,
aber es ist eine Fachlinguistik.
In Fachlinguistik, und zwar
sie hat uns auch erlaubt, ein paar Ausschnitte vorzulesen. Wir können ja mal fragen, ob wir sie veröffentlichen dürfen, sodass ihr sie euch auch durchlesen könnt. Und zwar, die Arbeit lautet, Stefan Tietze, ich finde, du bist ein toller Typ. Die Funktion von Vokativnutzung im medialen Gespräch. Ich will nicht sagen, dass es immer schon ein Traum von mir war, dass mein Name mal auf einer wissenschaftlichen Arbeit
im Titel steht, aber das ist schon ganz schön geil.
Die Funktion von
Vokativ-Nutzung im medialen
Gespräch, also es geht heute um den
Vokativ. Stefan, ganz kurzer
Abriss, was ist ein Vokativ? Als alter Lateiner
war ich mir bis gerade eben sicher,
dass es diesen Fall in Deutschland gar nicht
gibt. Aber ich glaube,
sie meint damit die direkte Ansprache. Ja. Einfach. Ja. Wenn man, wenn man, wenn ich jetzt sage, ey Florentin, Alter, pass mal auf hier, wir müssen weiter mal einen Podcast machen, dann ist es, glaube ich, die direkte Ansprache und würde man als Vokativ bezeichnen. Hör mal auf hier, pass mal auf. Also das heißt, sie hat dann ganz penibel auseinandergenommen und das Beste an der ganzen Arbeit sind die Ausschnitte aus den Gesprächen, die sie analysiert hat. Weil anscheinend gibt es so eine linguistische Schreibweise, wie man Gespräche transkribiert. Und das ist grossartig, weil da steht auch dann immer so die Betonung der einzelnen Worte mit Grossbuchstaben. Es sieht aus wie Kauderwelsch einfach, mit so ganz vielen Punkten. Und es steht immer so in so Zeilen aufgereiht und es steht auch so 0,7. Das steht für eine 0,7 sekündige Pause. Wahnsinn! Es wird in Millisekunden analysiert, wie wir sprechen, welche Pausen wir machen, welche Wörter, welche Wortteile wir betonen und es ist wirklich lächerlich. Es sieht aus wie die Matrix, in die man kurz schaut und man fühlt sich danach wie der grösste Vollidiot. Wir sprechen wie die grössten Deppen. Wollen wir mal einen Ausschnitt vorlesen? Hast du die Arbeit vor dir? Leider gerade nicht. Ja, Stefan. Ja, sorry, ich wusste nicht, dass ich jetzt darauf gefordert bin. Also wir lesen mal ganz kurz das Beispiel. Beispiel 1. Das erste Beispiel lässt sich zu Beginn der Folge bei Minute 3,41 verorten. Zuvor haben beide Sprecher sich begrüsst, sprachen über Geschmäcker von Lebensmitteln. Ganz kurz, wir müssen ganz kurz sagen, wir müssen ganz kurz sagen, dass wir davor gelobt wurden. Es wurde nämlich gesagt, dass wir tatsächlich gut sprechen. Und ihr könnt jetzt euch mal, wir beweisen euch mal, wie gut wir sprechen. Im ersten Beispiel. Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch an diese legendäre Szene, und zwar schreibt sie hier. Zuvor haben beide Sprecher sich begrüsst, sprachen über Geschmäcker von Lebensmitteln, das beste Thema ever, und Stefan Tietze schloss eine Geschichte über seinen Lehrer ab. Florentin Will isst Nüsse und berichtet von seiner Suche nach dem Effekt der Woche. Es tut mir so leid, sie untersucht uns und du isst Nüsse. Das ist lächerlich. Er spielt damit auf die zahlreichen, im vorigen Folgen aufgestellten und archivierten Rubriken des Podcasts an. Er hat den Lazarus-Effekt zum Effekt der Woche erklärt und fragt Stefan Tietze durch eine direkte Ansprache, was dieser sei. Stefan Tietze antwortet und die Antwort wird von Florentin Will evaluiert. So, gehen wir jetzt in den Dialog? Ganz kurz. Die Erklärung, was genau der Lazarus-Effekt ist, wird in diesem Ausschnitt nicht geliefert, sondern erst zur späteren Stelle im Podcast. Jetzt lesen für Sie Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will einen Ausschnitt aus Folge 118, Sohle. Der Ausschnitt Sohle, das ist so armsiglich. Bei Minute drei, einundvierzig. Man muss es timen, weil da sind die Minuten. Also genau, wir müssen es einhalten, die Millisekunden Pause. Und links hast. Und links darfst du auf FW stehen. Gut. Ich bin SD.
Ach, los geht's.
Der Effekt der Woche, 0,7 Sekundenpause, möchte ich kurz ankündigen, 0,4 Minuten Pause. Ankündigen.
Oh Mann, ey, jetzt habe ich die ganze Zeit so Nussstücke im Mund.
Ja, 0,4 Sekunden Pause.
Der Effekt, das ist Lachen, glaube ich.
Was ist H und Gradzeichen? Haarkreis ist Lachen. Und darunter ist H-H. Achtung, das ist längeres Lachen. Achtung, der Effekt der Woche. H-H-H. Ich war wieder auf der Suche nach einem Effekt. Ich möchte euch einen neuen Effekt präsenzieren. Sie versprochen vielleicht. Sie versprochen, präsenzieren. Präsenzieren. Und? Und den Lazarus-Effekt. Und den Effekt, den ich euch diese Woche vorstellen möchte, ist der Lazarus-Effekt. 0,8 Sekunden Pause. Du hast meinen Namen vergessen. Stefan Tietze. Stefan Tietze, 1,1 Sekunden Pause. Was ist der Lazarus-Effekt? Jetzt ist eine lange Pause. Das ist der Effekt, wenn du zu nah an die Sonne fliegst. 0,3 Sekunden Pause? Du merkst, je näher du an die Sonne fliegst, desto mehr merkst du, dass du keine Ahnung hast, was der Lazarus-Effekt eigentlich ist? 0,6 Sekunden Pause. Und dann verbrennst du an der Sonne, weil du ... Völlig richtig, da überschneiden sich nämlich die beiden, völlig richtig, 100 Punkte für Stefan Tietze. Dankeschön. 0,7 Sekunden Pause, Ende des Auszugs. Also, es ist erstaunlich und es ist wirklich erschreckend, weil aufgeschrieben, man wirkt wie der größte Depp der Welt. In dem Ausstatt wirst du wie der größte Depp. Präsensieren. Ich musste gerade ein bisschen lachen an meine Antworten. Du merkst, je näher du in die Sonne fliegst, desto mehr merkst du, dass du keine Ahnung hast, was in der Lasserobe Welt eigentlich ist. Dieses eingeschobene Lachen. Also, präsensieren. So, jetzt haben wir hier aber den Vokativ, glaube ich.
Ja, weil du mich ansprichst.
Weil ich dich anspreche.
Und das offensichtlich, was ich ja gar nicht gemerkt habe in diesem Moment, aber was so offenbar interessant ist für Leute, die sich wissenschaftlich mit Sprache beschäftigen, dass es untersuchungswert war, dass du mich manchmal ansprichst und ich dich. Und jetzt die Analyse geht so. Zu Beginn des Gesprächsausschnitts konstruiert Florentin Will eine Preface bei 01 und 03,
du mit deinen Prefaces immer, in welchen
er ein neues Thema, den Effekt der Woche,
durch einen Hauptakzent auf
Woch ankündigt.
Darauf folgt bei 05 eine Einschubsequenz,
in dem ebenfalls von FW
auf einen in der vorangegangenen
Konversation entstandenes Thema,
in Klammern, Essen von Nüssen,
das ist das Thema, das eingegangen wird. Dieser Einschub wird durch die beiden Pausen. Oh, das ist ein Fehler. Oh, und du hast es erst nach uns an den Prof geschickt. Also es ist noch nicht korrigiert. Oh, oh, oh, bei 0204 Kennzeichen und eine weitere Gesprächsebene wird etabliert. Im Anschluss bestätigt Stefan Tietze das Rederecht für Florentin Will, indem er zunächst durch ein Ja signalisiert, dass er sich kooperativ zum neuen Thema verhält. Und da möchte ich ganz kurz was zu sagen. Ihr lacht immer bei uns so. Aha, die ist chaotisch und so. Nein, da ist Technik dahinter. Das ist alles das Perfekte. Das ist alles Technik. Das ist natürlich auch mit dem Ja signalisiert, dass sich Ja und. Ein Ja und denken. Dass du dich kooperativ zeigst, dass du dem Gespräch nicht abgeneint hast. Das ist wichtig für mich. Das ist wichtig für den Podcast auch, weil sonst würde der Podcast gar nicht stattfinden. Natürlich muss ich Bock aufs Reden haben, aber mit dem Ja, es ist ein Ja und Denken. Erst der Gag danach ist erst möglich, weil ich dich in dem Thema bestätige. Perfekt. Danach folgt von FW die Exploration des eingeleiteten Themas zum Effekt der Woche. Hierbei ist auffällig, dass FW das Wort Effekt fünfmal wiederholt, weil er ein absoluter Vollidiot ist. Und immer den Hauptakzent der Phrase trägt, mit Ausnahme von 014, wo der Hauptakzent auf La liegt. Das hier nur den Effekt spitz... Entschuldigung, an der Stelle, ich möchte mich entschuldigen, dass ich da den Hauptakzent auf La gelegt habe. War ein Fehler, war Quatsch, ich nehme es hier zurück. Sorry, Leute. Was willst du sonst sagen?, oben hat sie bestätigt, dass du auf Woche, Woche auf Woche betont hast. Du, ich finde es, ey, wie willst du es denn sonst betonen? Ich nehme das Feedback auch gerne an, sie ist Profi und sie analysiert das und wenn sie sagt, das war Quatsch, hier den Akzent auf La zu legen, dann nehme ich das zurück. Lazarus oder was, was willst du denn sonst sagen? Das Wort Effekt wird hier nicht wiederholt, um das Thema für ST eindeutig zu zeigen, sondern vielmehr um den Hörern eine neue Rubrik zur Archivierung zu bieten.
Das ist Hörerservice, das ist subtiler Hörerservice, den merkt ihr gar nicht.
Leute lieben das Wort Effekt, das kann man gar nicht oft genug sagen. Also Wahnsinn, sie geht hier noch weiter. Ich würde noch ganz gerne ein zweites Beispiel vorlesen.
Nee, ganz kurz, es wird auch gelobt, dass ich humoristisch reagiere. Wirklich? Ja. Das ist mir gar nicht eingefallen. Reagiert FW dann auf die Reaktion von ST zu der zuvorgestellten mit einer ironischen Antwort, in Klammern, 100 Punkte für Stefan Tietze, und evaluiert somit die Sequenz mit Hilfe der erneuerten Nutzung des Vokativs. An dieser Stelle kommt es zu einer kurzen Überlappung beider Sprechtexte, welche sich jedoch schnell organisiert, indem St. schon in die Evaluation von FW mit Dankeschön antwortet. Aber hier kommt noch davor, hast du natürlich meinen Lob vergessen. Nach der Frage reagiert St. mit einer anscheinend dispräferierten Folge, da er nicht die richtige Antwort gibt, allerdings anzeigt, dass er die Erwartung von FW an ihn, eine Antwort zu geben, verstanden hat, indem er hier einen intertextuellen Verweis, ich weiß, ich muss aufhören beim intertextuellen Verweisen, auf die Icarus-Sage zu nah an die Sonne fliegen in seine Antwort einbaut, zeigt er die ironische Interpretation von FWs Frage an. Du bist so gut! Ebenfalls, und nicht nur das, ebenfalls etabliert es Tee mit der dispräferierten Folge eine zweite Ebene, beziehungsweise Bühne des Gesprächs, die nicht mehr dafür bestimmt ist, in der Interaktion mit FW zu reagieren, sondern um den eigenen Witz von den Hörern auszuprobieren. Alter, also du bist ein Meister am Mikrofon. Weißt du, die Übersetzung davon ist Bam-Bam-Bam. Nicht nur den Gag raushauen, sondern auch eine Bühne klar machen. Alter, du bist so gut.
Bam, bam, bam. Beispiel zwei. Ein Beispiel schauen wir uns noch an. Das zweite Beispiel beginnt bei Minute 35,57 nach einer längeren Diskussion der beiden Sprecher über die verschiedenen Länder Europas und deren Beziehung zueinander.
FW stellt anschließend die Behauptung auf, ST kaufe sich Wasser mit Geschmack und dies sei eine Eigenschaft, die ihm nicht gefalle und die er nicht verstehe. ST bestätigt diese Behauptung, daraufhin beginnt FW seine Vorstellung von Wasser mit Geschmack zu präzisieren und führt dafür die Situation des im Supermarktstehens an und unterscheidet ein Wolvik, in Klammern, Wasser mit Geschmack, von Schaumweinen und Softdrinks. Schaumweinen? Ihr hätte schwören können, dass wir das Wort Schaumwein noch nie genutzt haben. Im späteren Verlauf des Gesprächs, welcher hier nicht abgebildet ist, stellt ST klar, welches Wasser er trinkt und FW, warum er dies nicht mag. An welchem Punkt sagt der Professor, Alter, das interessiert mich kein, ich glaube, der Professor hat diese Arbeit nicht zu Ende gelesen. Du kriegst so eine Note, die sagt, der Professor hat es nicht gelesen, so eine 2 plus oder so, wo man nicht sagt, also bei einer 1 plus würde man sagen, okay, der Lehrer war sehr begeistert, da ist sehr viel Arbeit reingeflossen, bei einer 4 minus würde man sagen, okay, das ist eine sehr konkrete Note, da ist sehr viel evaluiert worden, aber das ist doch keine Arbeit. Da kriegst du einen Zweifel. Wie mühsam ist es denn, sich durch die Transkription eines Podcasts durchzuarbeiten. So, wir stellen vor. Ich fange dies mal an. Gut. Andere Kulturen. Wir müssen die Karte, glaube ich, nochmal komplett neu zeichnen. 0,4 Sekunden Pause. Einfach es, es muss gewisse Formen
geben.
Stefan,
tize ich, 0,4 Sekunden Pause,
find du bist ein toller Typ,
0,7 Sekunden Pause, aber, 0,2
Sekunden Pause, es gibt manche
Sachen, die gefallen mir nicht an
dir, 0,4 Sekunden Pause, zum
Beispiel, 0,2 Sekunden
Pause, du bist einer der wenigen Menschen, die kaufen sich Wasser mit Geschmack. 0,1 Sekunden Pause. Wasser mit Geschmack? Was bin ich denn für ein Vollendtourette? Das ist nichts, was ich sage. Einfach wiederhol im Supermarkt Wasser mit Geschmack. 0,3 Sekunden Pause. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht irgendwie 0,5 Sekunden Pause ein so ein Schaumwein im weitesten Sinne. Sprite meinst du? Sondern ein... Dankeschön, Stefan. Das war es von mir. Ciao. Sondern ein Wolwig. Dopp, hä, wie gut es ist, wie, also was für merkwürdige Dinge man im Gespräch macht, die einem dann erst auffallen, wenn man merkt, dass ich sage. Aber ich habe dich wirklich wiedererkannt, also weil so sprichst du. Manchmal sehe ich im Supermarkt was damit Geschmack und damit meine ich jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein, und dann machst du mal so kurze Pausen und dann ziehst du mal so ein, ja, meine 0,3 Sekunden Pausen. Hier, wieder kennst du ihn, berühmt.
Zu Beginn des Ausschnitts werden zuerst von ST und dann von FW das vorherige Thema evaluiert. Darauf folgt eine Atempause von FW, welcher das Fokale Element dem Vokativ Stefan Tietze vorbereitet. Dieses bildet hier den initialen Turn für ein neues Thema. Man könnte den Vokativ hier wirklich in einer Art Summons-Funktion sehen, da FWST nochmal direkt adressiert, sprachlich verdeutlicht den Hauptakzent auf Ste und auch im folgenden auf seine Person eingeht, durch das Ich unmittelbar nach dem Vokativ. Ich verstehe wirklich nicht. Ich verstehe wirklich nicht, warum man das alles, also du sagst doch nicht Stefan. auch, wenn du ein Vollidiot bist, sagst du Stefan. Es geht ja nicht nur darum, wie du das Wort betonst, sondern auch, was du akzentuierst. Also jedes Wort betonst du ja irgendwie. Ja, genau. Aber sie hat ja auch zum Beispiel das Wort Supermarkt. Das hat sie komplett klein geschrieben, obwohl ich ja Supermarkt sage und nicht Supermarkt. Da geht es auch darum, eine Stellung im Satz. Ich glaube, es geht darum, um die Sprachmeldung.
Es ist aber auch nicht so richtig eine Wissenschaft.
Das ist auch viel Quatsch.
Ja, durch das Ich unmittelbar nach dem Vokativ und die gleichbleibende Tonhöhe am Ende seiner Intonationsphase sichert sich F.W. das Rederecht für sein folgendes Preface,
da er durch diese anzeigt, dass nach der Adressierung ein personenbezogenes Thema etabliert werden soll
und der Kontext sich ändert.
Wow. Literaturverzeichnis Primärliteratur. www.pollox.fail. Slash Pufo 118-Bull-NP3. Aber Sekundärliteratur, ganz tolles Schlegelhoff, Mochigemba, Dennis Goffmann, Erving. Dennis Mochigemba? Mochi! Mochi! Mochi! Ja, großartig. Wir fragen mal nach, ob wir das veröffentlichen können. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall großartig, das nochmal komplett anzugehen. Und es wurde ein großes Fazit und sie analysiert das über weite Teilen. Ich habe das Fazit nicht 100% verstanden. Vielleicht können wir sie mal telefonisch zuschalten. Eigentlich müssen wir das mal machen. Wir können sie mal telefonisch einladen. Es wird ein komplettes Telefonprogramm. Ja, ja, aber ich muss sagen, ich finde es schon interessant, ich habe es nicht verstanden, einfach, vor allem keine Kritik an deiner Hausarbeit, aber du bist nicht zum Ergebnis gekommen, meiner Meinung nach, also schon eine Kritik an deiner Hausarbeit, weil ich finde, man könnte das schon, ich habe nicht ganz verstanden, was wir mit dem Vokativ bezwecken wollen. Ich glaube, das Fazit ist, wir sprechen uns gegeneinander an, um das Gespräch am Laufen zu halten.
Ich habe es eher so verstandenstanden, es war so die Frage, warum sollte man sich ansprechen, will man eine Bühne? Ich glaube, die Frage war, ist das Podcast eher eine Bühne oder ein Gespräch, wo zufällig ein Mikrofon läuft? Also eher Theaterstück oder eher Gespräch? Also inwiefern nehmen wir auf den Hörer bezug? Und ich glaube, wir sind eher Theaterstück, weil wir durchaus teilweise auf den Hörer bezug nehmen. Vor allem durch sowas wie direkte Ansprache, indem wir den Leuten vorstellen, auch Themen von privaten Gesprächen nicht machen würden. Da würde man nicht sagen, so, Stefan Tietze, was hast du denn letzte Woche gemacht? Würde man nicht machen. Mit 4-4-Prozent-Pause. Nee, würde man Weird. Die hat, die saß wirklich da und hat mit der Stoppuhr 0, teilweise 0,1 Sekunden Pause, 0,1 also ich verstehe 0,9 Sekunden Pause, 0,1 Weißt du wie man das macht? Man spielt es einfach langsamer ab, was das noch lächerlicher macht. Du machst die Wellenform, oder? Die Vorstellung, dass sie so langsam unseren Podcast abspielt, dass sie das stoppt durch sechzigfacher Geschwindigkeit. So, ganz kurz. An alle Linguistik-Studenten da draußen, die nicht wissen, über was sie in der Hausarbeit schreiben sollen. Schreibt bitte über das Gespräch, das wir gerade geführt haben, über diese Hausarbeit. Schreibt darüber bitte eine Hausarbeit und paraphrasiert das, wie wir das vorgelesen haben, nochmal selbst in so einer Textanalyse. Und dann geht das immer weiter für den Rest der Zeit und irgendwann haben wir das gesamte Feld der Linguistik übernommen, weil nur noch Leute über Podcast-Ufo schreiben und nur noch unsere Gespräche über die Gespräche, die gesprächsanalisiert wurden, analysiert werden. Das wird grossartig. Aber jede Arbeit soll heißen, Stefan Tietze, ich finde, du bist ein toller Typ. Ja, genau. Und dann die These, ja. Und dann die These, die neue These. Du, und somit ist es jetzt wissenschaftlich, Stefan Tietze, ich finde, du bist ein toller Typ. Ist es jetzt wissenschaftlich bewiesen, dass ich ein toller Typ bin?, wenige Leute können aber sich sagen, dass es wissenschaftlich bestätigt ist, dass ich ein toller Typ bin. Dass ich ein toller Typ bin. Ich weiß aber nicht, ich habe das Ergebnis nicht verstanden. Im Fazit stand nicht, ob ich ein toller Typ bin. Das ist mir vielleicht negativ aufgefallen bei der Arbeit. Du kannst, du musst ja bei so einer wissenschaftlichen Arbeit immer gegen Ende ein bisschen was offen lassen. Du brauchst ja so ein bisschen so eine Krümel-Zuerte. Das ist schon eine Schwafelarbeit. Das ist schon so eine Schwafel. Das Du hast dir Mühe gegeben im anderen Fach und dann hast du das Fach genommen, Linguistik, der Professor war eh nett, da komm, dann mache ich da das Podcast so vor. Ich glaube, es wirkt auf Außenstehende immer wie Schwafelarbeit, jede Arbeit. Ich glaube, selbst eine gute linguistische Arbeit würde für uns genauso wie eine Schwafelarbeit sich lesen wie eine schlechte. Also ich glaube, von außen kann man das nicht bewerten. Vielleicht ist das jetzt brillant, dass sie das analysiert hat mit dem deskriptiven Turn, wann das Gespräch, Preface. Von daher ist es schwer zu sagen, wenn man nicht drinsteckt. Ist schwer zu sagen. Man weiß es nicht. Wow, wir haben ganz schön was abgearbeitet heute. Heute war nicht mehr so eine lockere Folge, heute war so eine, wie ihr es gewohnt seid von uns, mit unseren kleinen Pausen und Betonungen, nein, heute war eine Vortragefolge und wir hoffen, dass wir trotzdem ein bisschen Spaß haben. Wir haben was abgearbeitet, ab jetzt sind Ferien, ab jetzt lassen wir uns wieder locker gehen, locker angehen. Kleiner Funfact, wo ich gerade in Hand habe, in ein Chubachubs-Lolli, unten in diesem Loch, in dieses Loch vom Chubachubs-Lolli, passt genau eine Lego-Hand, passt genau da rein, wo ich mir denke, hat dann jemand gesagt, dieses Loch da unten, das machen wir genauso groß, wie man, wenn man angenommen, man könnte da so eine Lego-Hand reinstecken, das wäre ungefähr die perfekte Grösse für Chupa Chups. Es gibt bei Lego-Sets tatsächlich verbotene Arten, Lego-Steine zu verbinden. Es gibt ja mehrere Arten, wie man zwei Lego-Steine verbindet. Das kommt dann, die Lego-Polizei oder was? Und es gab gewisse Techniken, die Lego früher verwendet hat, die sie jetzt nicht mehr verwenden. Zum Beispiel, ein bisschen Fantasie jetzt, Achtung. Es gibt ja einmal die dicken Lego-Steine und die dünnen. Oh mein Gott, ja. Die dünnen, ne? Sind die im Verhältnis zwei zu ... Eins zu drei. Eins zu drei, ja. Drei dünne sind so dick, ein dickes. So, und jetzt diese dünnen sind ja genau so hoch wie der Abstand zwischen zwei Knubbeln. Ja. Soweit alles klar? Ja. Das heißt, du kannst es sozusagen im 90-Grad-Winkel im 90-Grad-Winkel kannst du eines dieser dünnen Plätzchen im 90-Grad-Winkel zwischen die Knubbel stecken. Und es gibt ein Set von Lego, wo das so tatsächlich in der Anleitung steht.
Weil man es machen muss.
Was ist der Heiss?
Und zwar ist es die Antenne auf einer Polizeistation.
Weil das ist so ein 1x8, glaube ich, 1x8, also ganz dünnes, schmales Ding, wo ganz oben noch so ein roter Knopf ist für rot oder irgendein Leuchter für die Helikopter, glaube ich, oder sowas.
Und das ist auf das Dach von der Polizeistation so draufgeknipst und seitdem wird das nie wieder verwendet.
So das erste Teil, was abfällt. Der erste Teil, wenn der Vater wütend das ins Schrank stellt, weil das Kind nicht damit spielt.
Aber ich finde das total abgefahren, dass es so illegale Bautechniken gibt, die bei Lego nicht mehr verwendet werden. Also dass es da so Regeln gibt, wonach man seine Sets bauen darf. Die hören doch auch die ganzen Telefonate ab. Die passen doch genau auf. Die haben die auf dem Schirm. Wenn du das machst, wenn du Lego so baust, haben die auf dem Schirm. Also Leute, aufpassen. Mach mal zu Hause, nehm mal zwei Legosteine, steck die so zusammen und dann guck mal, welche Autos vor der Tür vorbauen. Vor allem, du kannst kostenlos Teile nachbestellen bei Lego, das ist ganz cool. Ja, aber es sind teure Teile. Nee, nein, wie gesagt, kostenlos nachstellen. Was ist das teuerste? Ja, sorry. Und dann kannst du tatsächlich, wenn du willst, könntest du dir nach und nach den Millennium-Falken holen, indem du immer wieder hinschreibst und sagst, hat gefehlt leider, bei mir hat das folgende Teil gefehlt,
und dann musst du halt
1.398 Mal. Haben sie die letzte Woche schon
geschrieben? Was? Nein, das war mein Bruder,
Befan Tietze.
Das war mein Bruder, Stefan Tietze.
Kennen Sie vielleicht aus der Linguistik-Arbeit? Ja, und das kannst du jedenfalls
machen. Also bestell uns gerne mal
Lego-Teile. Wertvollster Legostein.
Ja.
Fuss.
Fuss von diesen Figuren.
Es gibt keine Füße.
Na klar.
Die Beine haben.
Und die Beine.
Nein.
Wo man schon, ja, wo man nämlich schon dieses Ding, wo man es einrastet, wo man quasi verschiedene Stufen, wenn du zum Beispiel ein Dach aufmachst von einem Flieger oder Helikopter, dann gibt es verschiedene Stufen, wo man das zumachen kann.
Ja, da denke ich mir, das ist clever, das ist clever, abgerissen.
Es ist tatsächlich der rote Darth Vader-Helm.
Das war das Podcast-Uwe von dieser Woche. Beben ab und sagen Tschau, bis zum nächsten Woche.